so
i was debating whether to record this
video
but i feel like
it's kind of a necessity
uh i woke up this morning i grabbed some
breakfast with friends as we see in this
photo
and then i went over to the chess club
to watch
some of the players arrive for sync
field cup
and all the players arrived for their
games
except magnus carlson
[Music]
so even before there was any official
announcement
i kind of knew that something was going
on
and then shortly after the round was
scheduled to start
magnus tweeted
that he is withdrawing from the
steamfield cup
and seems to leave out a lot of
information or explanation
and um yeah it's it's too early for me
to comment on anything i know there's a
lot of speculation going on
online and on social media but i just
want to make sure
people are aware of this
and i was planning to post my game
analysis
the game i played against magnus carlsen
a few days ago at the opening ceremony
simon i really hope i'm not the reason
why he dropped out
because we did have a hotly contested
game he talked a little bit of trash
talk
and i just made a thumbnail for the
video which i do plan to post
probably in a few hours after this one i
want to keep this video very brief
i spent a lot of time doing some fun
analysis
uh for our our recap video so be sure to
stay tuned for that
but for now
that's pretty much all i have to say
keep it real and i'll see you guys soon